what's going on everybody welcome to the
14th Python tkinter and building a
actual tkinter application tutorial
series in this video we're going to be
adding more options more of the backend
that we need to add so let's go ahead
and it started we're going to come down
to cVTC app and continue editing
basically where we've been between the
minibar options and tktk config come
down here and now we're going to add
some more options we're going to add
basically the timeframe of data and then
also the actual open high low close bars
what's the timeframe for those as well
so the window so we're going to go ahead
and say data TF and this will be the
time frame of data so are we going to
look at one day of data three days of
data week of data so on
so then TF equals T KDOT mint capital n
menu and then we've got a menu bar and
then we're going to also allow this to
be a tear-off Sottero of equals one and
then we're going to say data TF dot add
underscore command the label for this
command cat R oh sorry it's under case L
label will equal tick and then we're
going to do comma enter and then we're
going to say command equals lambda colon
and then this will be a function change
time frame and then we're going to
change that time frame to tick data and
that's it so now we're gonna have a few
more options so let's go ahead and
highlight this copy and then um
basically paste mmm
three more times so one two three so
we've got tick data then we're going to
have one day and then change time frame
to one D and then we'll have here this
will be a three day I'll check capital D
there change time frame to 3d and then
here we'll have one week change time
frame seven D for seven days and then
we're going to add this so this will be
menu bar dot ad underscore cascade the
label will equal data time frame comma
menu will equal data TF okay easy enough
um now that we've done that well let me
see if we can go ahead and toss in one
more group of stuff so we're going to
say Oh H low close then I'm going to go
ahead and say I here I honestly cannot
remember what I meant I to be but
capital o hplc could conflict with other
things other functions so we want to
just go ahead and we're throwing an eye
in there I got I would say indicator but
that's not what I meant
so I don't know but that is what I used
for the letter so anyway you can call
whatever the heck you want but just so
it jogs with the actual github I'm gonna
leave it as I so open high/low close i
equals t KDOT menu and then we want this
on the menu bar and then again this one
will be able to be turned on or off turn
off then we're going to say ohlc
i dot ad underscore command and then
this is basically you know at what kind
of data are we looking at again we're
going to allow it to pass through tick
so what i'm going to go ahead and do is
basically highlight this right here and
just do like this so copy and then paste
and so because people might consider
open high/low close like what kind of
time frame are we going to use my still
want to find tick there just in case but
otherwise they're gonna want a different
different stuff so we'll leave tick
there for now but then we'll come
through we'll copy that paste and now
we're going to call this option one
minute so this is one minute bars and
then instead of change time frame we're
going to call this change sample size
and change sample size is going to take
a few pram or two parameters basically
the first is the sample size so we'll
call this one
sample size so the bars will be one
minute open high low close data so one
minute and then the second parameter is
going to be the width of the candlestick
so if you have a high granularity data
set here the candlestick with needs to
be very small because you're gonna have
a lot of candles but if you don't have
very many candles it's hard to read if
the candlestick is really small so here
this is where we set the actual width of
the candlestick and this is the program
name for the change sample size now
we're going to take the same optionality
here we'll copy come down here paste uh
let's just paste a bunch that might do
it we want a bunch of them so anyway we
got one minute a five minute fifteen
minute uh 30 minute one hour one hour
and then we're gonna call this three
hour class only got one extra would have
been nice to get it perfect but anyway
okay so these are the time frames that
we want right now so now you got one
minute five minute 15 minute 30 minute
and then we have one H and then we'll
call this one 3 H and then so for the
one minute zero zero five for five
minutes point zero zero three for 15
minutes point zero zero eight again
these are the widths of the candlestick
you'll see what I mean
once we visualize the candlestick 30
minute point zero one six one hour point
zero three two and then finally point
zero nine six four three hours finally
uh whoops Oh finally we'll come down
here and we'll just say menu bar dot add
underscore cascade label Wow how is that
label label don't go crazy guys label
open high/low close interval and then
the menu that we're adding here is
actually ohlc
i okay so looks like I've jammed that in
about six minutes so we have time to
actually make these functions now so if
you are lost you might want to pause
right here make sure you got all that
data otherwise we're going to continue
on without you so moving up to the very
very top now we've got a couple more
well really just one major um constant
basically to add here it's not really a
constant it's a variable but whatever
anyway resample size and that's going to
start as 15 minutes so the deep these
are basically the defaults and then the
user can change them later so the
default exchange is btc-e the default
counter is 9000 because it's going to
restart immediately the default sample
size will be 15 minutes and now we're
going to go ahead and we're going to say
define change time frame if you recall
there was only one parameter that passed
through here which was going to be time
frame so i'll just say TF so in change
time frame what we want is we want to
have dat counter but then also we're
going to have data pace actually so
we're gonna have data pace here and
that's just going to be like how big of
a data set do we have and so we're going
to go ahead and default to 1d for one
day so the default graph that's going to
pop up is going to be TC exchange it's
going to be one day's worth of pricing
data and it's going to be sampled at
15-minute open high low close
candlestick bars basically so change
timeframe TF we're going to global data
pace and then we're also going to global
dat counter and then we're going to say
if TF equals a 70 for example and a
resample sized resample
size equals 1 minute : so if this is the
case like we're asking for a week's
worth of data and we're trying to plot
it with one minute open high low close
bars that's too much data it's going to
be just a really messy ugly graph so if
the user tries to do that we're going to
throw a pop-up message and that message
will be too much data
too much data chosen choose a smaller
time frame time frame or higher open
high low close sample size open high low
close I think we call that interval so
yeah we'll do interval okay and as time
goes on we'll probably add some other
sample sizes so right now the largest
sample size is you Skype is one week so
maybe the user wants to see one month or
six months okay so as time goes on we'll
add larger ones so if the user chooses
six months of a data frame well 15
minutes is probably too small so
anything under 15 minutes a sample size
with a timeframe of 3 months is too much
or six months or whatever I said so um
so we'll need that we'll end up having a
lot more of these as time goes on so so
we've got that and now we're going to
say if that so else we're gonna say data
data pace equals the time frame and then
since there's been a modification we're
going to set dat counter to 9,000 and
that will force an update later on that
you'll understand more when we get there
so now that we've done that the other
thing that we have is a sample size okay
so so we're going to come down to two
here and we're going to say define
change
sample size and this will be size width
if you recall so this was the actual
sample size so the time length basically
the bar and this was the width of the
candlestick bar so then we're going to
need a global resample size then we're
going to global that counter and then
finally we're going to global candle wit
and can't wait doesn't exist yet so
let's go ahead and make that so candle
width and we said that our resample size
was 15 minutes so if we scroll down here
to 15 minutes we'll see the default we
should have is point zero zero eight so
we'll scroll back up to the very very
top candle wit default 0.008 now that
we've done that we're gonna say um
basically the same thing as before so if
if this is the case we'll copy that
paste and eventually probably what we'll
do is we'll make like one massive
function that just runs through all of
these checks like is any of these things
true and if so that's too much data but
for now we'll just copy and paste this
this single line since that's really
only the only line that we have that
would be a conflicting amount but
there's one more problem so if the user
is trying to change a sample size for
the open high low close data but they're
viewing tick data um that makes no sense
so we're going to have a warning here so
if data pace equals tick if that's the
case then we're gonna have a pop-up
message that just says uh you're
currently viewing tick data not open
high/low open a little close um okay
that's that so um if if and then else if
those two things are not the case and
really this is if this price this we
really need to run this as an L if and
then this will be else so that was kind
of a bit of a
my because basically this if will run
and then this if were to run and the
else would have only pertained to that
if there so anyway moving on else Rhys
ample sized the equals size I can mean
finding bugs in my program that counter
will equal nine thousand because we made
a change when we're forcing update
chairs and you could have made instead
of DAC Cantor you could have said force
update equals true
anyway attack counter equals nine
thousand and then finally candle wit
vehicles with bone done so now we've
whoops that should be wit like that now
we're ready to go let's go ahead and
test this and to test it let's make our
time frame seven days and choose a
sample size of one minute see what
happens
run it hopefully no errors see any yet
I'll hit agree so now I'll do a one week
time frame there and then we'll go open
high low close one minute up got a bug
name TF not defined um that's
interesting because it's big past TF
here
change timeframe if TF makes no sense
I'm looking at it right now as something
we're passing through a function hold on
hold on out everybody wait name TF not
define if TF equals seven day and
resample sighs that's line 52 in change
sample size that's here um okay so
resample sons change two numbers yeah so
well it's not actually occurring in this
function it's occurring in this function
so what we're going to go ahead and do
is if what we need to be is if data pace
that's interesting because this is a
another glitch or problem in my program
if database equals seven days we have
data D along here this needs to be a
capital D data pace okay let's try that
again
um yeah I was looking in the other
function for some reason now so go uh
one week for the data time frame and
then we'll go one minute I still didn't
get my error one week oh there we go too
much data chosen I wonder why did it
happen the other way around okay I guess
it is I don't know I maybe an update
occurred or something anyway so now now
it appears to me that our function is
correctly working so again we still we
have you know the back end kind of logic
is in place the functionality still
isn't there we saw a few more things we
need to do before we start building that
cuz obviously we've had quite a few
options but we will get there we've got
the back end at this point and then
we'll just like I said we got PI well
three more videos and then we'll
actually start having these options
actually doing something to our graph
that'll be a lot more exciting so
anyways if you guys have any questions
or comments about this video please feel
free
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions until next
time